on this episode LFC stops by
[Music]
[Applause]
in
this is
Carrie be everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is episode 260 of
the askgaryvee show and I'm super fired
up Linda before I introduce you to
everybody
yeah I was watching a 34:30 which one
was that like in a mad dog he made an
appearance in that I did and yes the
whole Mike Piazza my favorite no no
perfect for me you look you look do you
know I know better now yeah better now
than men yeah incredible hair Thank You
les you're welcome so if you don't know
ready for the four people in the world
that don't know I'm here with Linda
Cohen who is who this is not a joke I
genuinely believe this is a legend and
I'm tough with throwing that around
because I want to be a legend and so I
don't like tearing and run so simply but
I genuinely believe that and so Linda
please for the audience that's watching
now that maybe hasn't been in sports
culture which would then mean maybe they
haven't seen your you haven't hit the
radar why don't you spend one minute on
who you are and then I've got some
questions I mean this is before I
apologize already cut you off before I
started is that what everybody's super
excited but the sushi dinner that you
and I had fabulous two months ago is
literally probably one of my favorite
dinners of all time
seriously it was amazing first of all we
were the only people in the restaurant
we owned it he did yes we did
second I was really amped up and brought
some serious deep sports knowledge with
jacket L through your eyes impressed you
it was amazing and also but the irony
was because you're all about taking
pictures visually they didn't let us
roll any camera I know the rock you got
kicked out that was that was actually
the best part is it like never happens
to you know what happened to all the
time okay really even that imposing
figure that he is yeah you know with
that all right let me tell it tell
everybody who you sense all right
three cents three cents I just get three
cents okay nobody has hosted more sports
centers than me on okay hello especially
that one more time
all right nobody male or female has
hosted more sports centers on ESPN than
me let me talk cool all right
and I don't you know who knew was that
was the plan going in I was just doing
what I loved which is love and sports
and as you know having a passion for
something and saying what the hell let
me just do this so that's what I did and
I just got into the Hall of Fame but
here's the thing Gary which calling the
broadcaster yeah now is worth sports
maybe a hall official real quick I need
to for you to and that was weird because
I'm far from done Gary Rama where I know
how yeah we haven't even get out of
there okay but before you get to that
part now is the sports what is it what's
the official the official answer though
yeah I don't know Google me what it is
thanks national sports muley horn effect
now is this a [ __ ] Hall of Fame like
we have in the advertising whole thing
so there's an advertising Hall of Fame
in our world and like people that are
just getting started or getting in it
like Marin Bauman's in it the bond is
amazing but he's not ready to be in a
Hall of Fame is this a real one yeah or
a [ __ ] one yes Vin Scully was one of
them I was the weakest person in this
whole thing it's not about who the best
person is right it's about who the week
you make sense but it's like Craig
Kilborn in it now okay okay all right
yeah no okay if you had you would have
mentioned Craig Kilborn in my time your
honor Gary on show I would have been
like please no yeah I loved his 18
minutes yeah I mean it was for the best
okay so okay I know this story but I'm
going to ask you to say it can I tell
you my little story first you could do
anything all right because you know
again I when I go to a place and your
humble home which is amazing with all
your amazing humans around me there's a
lot um I can't come empty-handed and it
was you know so first of all because you
know because I know how much you love
tongue-in-cheek the Pittsburgh Penguins
I hate the penguin right now so I
thought after they won their second
straight family elsewhere I was on the
ice for sell abroad you bring this with
Sidney Crosby because I like stirring
the pot with you there so there it is
Willy okay I'm gonna take you I will not
be going I know this will not be
collecting in the bath no no I gold and
I'm going to take it home care about
real quick where's the cameras okay this
is going to I don't know if you're
watching one of my best friends in high
school Steve Nash Ryan is a huge penguin
fan when the Rangers lost the series
when graves brought broke his hands
that loss was the most devastating loss
I know they won a 94 what was at 92 93
they went 994 92 93 there is supposed to
win the car right that's the yeah like a
year and that definitely they lost the
past right
that lost to the pens besides let's
think of all-time moments when I cried
in sports all-time number top hello the
Sports Center thing you can we got to do
it I don't know if a gun pen alright
by the way let's make bread number six
through ten okay all jet games random
jacket well but here the time having to
say they no question more than 10
genuine losing Linda it's good I'm real
glad ah no question at number I should
probably go an order I'm gonna go an
order back I apologize for breaking this
but I want to get it right the time I
cried the most not even close all time
sports history was when the Jets lost to
the Browns of the 86 playoff game the
Jets were winning by 10 points with with
four minutes left in the game and had
the ball in Cleveland and somehow
miraculously lost in double overtime
that was number one number two was when
the Knicks lost Game seven to the rocket
94 correct cried like a baby my senior
year in high school
cried from 10:30 p.m. to 4:00 in the
morning when John Starks failed
basically to show up in that one that is
correct that crushed me number three yes
when Macho Man Randy Savage
lost the title to Hulk Hogan even though
I then I was mature enough to know that
the writing was on the wall and he was
going to lose and if they won / then it
was fake okay there was one percent
chance that he was going to win he
didn't and I cried for good to three
hours number four when the Rangers lost
to the pens
in that series that was the Ranger team
that I thought was going to win the Cup
that was a team that was devastating to
me I hate [ __ ] Pittsburgh yeah so
much that's why I thought that
and then I understand that and then
number five number five what do you
think another jet moment
yes I got so many rent I've got an
amazing around AJ had a lump under his
armpit when only three and my parents
and most doctors thought it was cancer
Wow
the Jets lose a random regular-season
game to the Packers during this time he
has early Favre the Jets lose a
devastating middle of the season game I
start crying my ass off there's a wreck
I'm 16 17 it's a regular season football
game I am crying like your dog died my
mom has been watching me cry over
jackings for years she looks me dead in
the face and loses her mind angry one of
the few times she was truly again she
said your brother is potentially like
like I don't know what she said in
Russian but she was like your brother
sick right she already went there and
she's like and you haven't cried once
and you're crying about this [ __ ] and I
was like yep and you're a teenager oh I
cried so hot actually actually thank you
for saying that
you triggered that's moving to number
six well I have the official number five
in the Jets regular season opener in
1999's all postseason yes in the Jets
regular season opener in 1999 a playoff
game you might remember this yes Linda
this is a very famous moment now the
Jets opening game in San Francisco they
lose in overtime because garrison Hearst
had a 98-yard running play do you
remember this I'll tell you former Niner
grade of the past
Harrison hircine ie man when we went to
overtime against you went into overtime
98 the just kicked the ball off to start
over time right the the bull behavior is
weird
none of great news the bull bounce is
weird and the Niners have to start on
the two I'm dreaming of getting a safety
to win the game right
carface hand the ball off to garrison
Hearst and he runs it 98 yards and you
know just then that didn't happen back
then during my eight yard seat we've
actually seen like 100 you up one-yard
version we're back yeah when they
started showing and they run your genius
what do you think 3040 all-time plays
over 98 yard like in overtime
just lose I just left college I was now
in New York I cry go in my car and stick
with me here drive to Boston incredible
I was so devastated was it I understand
my girlfriend I'm really sure that was
the paranoiac no do you rock not really
the truth you fell for it I cry all I
was definitely on it but I figured I'd
go see my girlfriend because I knew I
was going to work my ass off never see
her again all right which brings me to
my second attempt think I can attended a
low speed mash my high school friends
not the Steve Nash she used to play for
the Sun no no thank you
okay all right yeah we don't know what
he's doing but he's long retired so
there's other things speaking of the
Jets oh you know I got to credit my
brother
I want to unwrap what I'm excited we
thought was you know obviously huge fans
love the wall love the personality it's
all you and it's great and like you know
what so we're like let's get a
custom-made bobble head right wait wait
I'll build this up only for him sadly an
owner of the jet okay yes and something
happens along the way I'm off and I was
lost in translation and and you'll
recognize that this is nothing
apparently they're colorblind one so
it's altoon from its own face so
basically guys this is like Pat
Summerall because he wore number 88 back
in the day to the New York Football
Giants also like Enix okay so this looks
more personal it does this even look
like you drive bad news so first of all
it's so they screwed up it doesn't look
like me because there's not enough gray
hair number two guys but I think they've
got they nailed the five o'clock shadow
they did have Linda yeah I like that
Linda yes this is more of a patreon or
even a giant Jersey yeah yeah yeah you
know that right yeah guys know that
right I I was trying to take the high
road for you keep it in New York I'm not
putting this and obviously for two
neither item is making the Shelf
Thank You self you dis now leave me to
exactly how I wanted it to play out can
you will be the first ever to time
guests so I think we actually done that
with some people KC maybe I don't know
but anyway that you're coming back
everybody will get another attempt to
bring me again that sounds good
they obviously reason why they screwed
it up they must have told who the heck
would want to be the owner of the Jets
they must mean which I love it I mean I
will see ban soon thanks for coming on
under Linda look I love you Gary you
know I love how you know really really
one of the best it's really amazing how
much I adore you and how excited I was
for today Linda please now we've had a
lot of fun I'm sure people listening are
having a blast but please do the part of
this interview that's going to matter
the most we're going to get the cash in
soon Facebook please put in your phone
number we're going to call in we're
going to do a bunch and honestly I
always still think I'm probably going to
do a sports radio show really enough I
think there's a dark-horse chance that
Linda and I will do a sports radio show
together and be number one in the
country but before we get into that I
want you to tell us your career from
beginning to end or at least beginning
to spin Saturday I mean because I'll
play around the edges here's why that's
before relationships it's really
motivational to me and I rarely get
motivated this is incredibly powerful in
my biggest thesis you willed this into
existence in an ungodly quick time and
it just I feel like there's a lot of
people watching me right now I'm always
and listening I'm always trying to get
you to action I know a lot of people
listening right now pull over stop your
treadmill I mean this I mean this you
need to listen to these next four
minutes because this is the most
valuable thing that's going to happen to
show from beginning to end Linda go
alright thanks so much Gary here's the
deal
I live my dream I'm still living it
reason why I grew up loving sports I was
a kid with low self-esteem I wore thick
glasses I didn't feel good about myself
people laugh at that I grew up on Long
Island middle-class family what do I
have to feel sorry for but I didn't have
anything to look forward to sports gave
me that gave me something to look
forward to then I started playing hockey
street hockey and
Veronica Lee I was a goalie why was I
there was a goalie because I feel
comfortable being hidden okay because I
don't feel good about myself finally got
contact lenses realized I was a damn
good goalie you know I had tremendous
eye hand coordination ironically Gary
because I was so nearsighted yes but the
contacts helped and Lois very short it's
like contacts eye contact North right so
anyway I was a kid what got me back in
the day growing layers of tough skin to
be able to handle the job that I do now
and throughout the years thirty years in
the business at least it's the fact that
I played hockey with boys that were
seven and eight years old
ice hockey when I was 14 years old then
I was 15 they didn't let me play with
boys my age back in the day but I still
wanted a play I wore the goalie mask
ponytail sticking out of the mask moms
would Swiss / I'd hear the moms you know
what they would say what's that girl
doing on the ice playing with my son of
clay hockey I was just I love hockey why
can't I play hockey and so that kind of
helped me block out the noise so anyway
as we fast-forward that would be the
reason actually I get foundation that
was the foundation because I was always
doing something I loved and I didn't
know where it was going to lead yeah I
wanted it to lead to a NHL goalie job I
wanted to be in the NHL that was out of
your minds you did did you think that's
what's amazing it did because it was my
strength you know the feeling I got when
I made a big save and I saved the game
for my teammates I wanted to be in that
pressure situation
I lived for because suddenly I meant
something again kid with low self-esteem
used to listen to depressing music I
mean back in my day it was John Denver
in the carpenters all right you know we
have to bring up Karen Carpenter here
you just read or do I know so I'm a huge
fan emeritus but it's depressing so it
was a foundation and so I couldn't be an
NHL goalie okay so what can I do I
eventually played hockey with girls in
college and majored in broadcasting but
then this is what gets me excited Lynn
forget when I finally met you but when I
knew about you before I finally got to
meet and we had that great dinner at the
sushi place the thing is it's like God
I'm seeing myself because I knew I was a
24/7 girl I work seven days a week
trying to get a break I did radio I did
news
radio I did local Long Island cable TV
and I thought to listen what I wish the
rock filmed our first dinner because I
did none I always listened but through
my talking this dinner I did a lot of
listening so I really want you to go
through in detail what is your first so
you so you're doing broadcasting in
school yes now you do need communication
oh you do what you do obviously get
involved you know people know that now
now it's so awesome with social media
you can you can create your own persona
or people will see you back into my day
explore how to make a tape you had to
hope that news director or sports story
so how did he so as you're in school you
think I want to be a big-time sports ah
I didn't even say big-time I want a job
where I can talk about sports because
guess I'm out where was I dream OPLAN I
am how where was that for women it
didn't exist at that time could you look
at anybody at that point or there was no
role model I had no role model for women
sports
early 80s when I was doing radio uh and
news I didn't get a break in sports
until I worked for W CBS Radio 88 here
in New York City this was before WFAN
I'm aware and then I got to do updates
sports updates with WFAN they just have
anything going on I can leave I want
everybody yes I want everybody here
Ennis what is the first job you get and
how did you get it Patchogue Long Island
wal Kay radio 50,000 watt I did news
updates and you know what happened I
volunteered to cover you'll love this I
know that's why I'm a die-hard Ranger
fan the and I volunteered to cover the
hated New York Islander games at the
Nassau Coliseum an hour away the Nassau
Coliseum from from Patrick Long Island
where I did news updates
I created the idea I brought it to my
news director said listen I will go in
my little tape recorder and cover
Islander games I will file 45 second
radio reports you can put in your little
news updates for all to hear
just pay for my gas pay ten bucks for my
gas there and back you don't even have
to pay me extra what did that do Gary it
opens them yours I never kid you network
with metal approval I work for free to
get with with my eyes wide open not know
not knowing if there would be you know a
light at the end of this time I'm one of
my biggest most angry things in the
world is how many people don't like
working for free because and it's a very
big internet culture thing right it's
Eric's world it's my buddies freed and
DHHR like it's that it's that you should
get paid but it's completely not
factoring in supply and demand if
there's a million people that want that
thing and there's only eight things to
be done you've got a factor that reality
like I'm stuck be rock like so much of
my life like it's unbelievable how much
I believe in it if you want it if you
want but wait you're in control just cuz
somebody else is doing it you don't have
to when I thought that people that are
working for free are ruining it for
everybody else is not taking real life
into consideration exactly so you will
your way by doing that right without
what years was that this was a 1980 I
want to say 83 82 we had just won all
their cups yes and then I think I junks
them because they stopped winning right
so you need the review on a regular day
correct but you actually have crying
Gilligan this is something that needs to
be shared on social media quietly I
think that you actually Jake they want
four Stanley Cups in a way you start
covering them right
you're a real Rangers fan right and they
have not won a Cup since that's accurate
correct there is actually the cursive
linda cone on the islanders that's
accurate and i'm literally this women
this is like a t-shirt this is like a
meme this is like the reverse of 1940
this is this is did we just break this
is this could get really big in the
hockey community can we confirm because
I'm a little worried right now that your
first year might have even been a year
after or actually one day one I see you
thinking I am born as we're going to
Edmonton Oilers one in 1984 and they
finally promoted gene yes and I believe
I will tell a check but I believe rather
that is the ending we need to do some
real homework here because here's why if
true this can turn into a substantial
meme in hockey culture I believe
intuitively here on
episode 260 yeah the askgaryvee show we
have established sports second biggest
curse maybe third because the goat for
the Cubs let's make this burn Linda I
think the whole window home
I think I think I'm James and I think
that the Islanders will not win a
Stanley Cup until you go check what's
right well wait when we uh and by the
way the curse can continue if some of
the Rangers can get John Tavares who
hasn't been fine how long term about
injecting that would be awesome that
would be the Kurds I'll give you a heads
up we should double check while I'm
still here and it's still alive thank
you people Darla here the Islanders won
the Stanley Cup know that I know
o'night if that matches yeah I don't
have to like a big one yeah you get the
job doing the sports brief I wanna rub
way I'm having too much fun I you know I
need this whole thing in our radio show
when you go to Pacific Northwest great
to go to Calgary Alan right right forget
[ __ ] I have wanting to hear this yes I
believe that everybody watching right
now who wants to be a rapper who wants
to be a painter who wants to be a
start-up founder your story is so
important to me because of the couple of
things you did and why you did them and
how you did them in the face of your
marriages your I need you to tell it the
way you told to me because it's it's
going to help people so you hustle and
get your gas paid for free right you
start operating islands company out of
there keep going - shut up and then I
mean you know I made important people
again not knowing that it wasn't mean
anybody but what was I doing I was just
being myself following my passion
covering hockey and again you knew I
love hockey because it was covering the
team I hated the most and made me cry
like the Jets have made you cry as it's
been well-documented just right now so
but the revolt actually there's actually
that would be me covering the Patriots
yeah the Rangers and Jeff they drive the
reverse so if you actually covered the
p3s which is insane [ __ ] [ __ ] that's
going away that's a very good feeling
although I've seen enough Ranger
Islander games for the rate I've been in
their dressing women they're crying
after Islander losses yeah a novelty
poppy that's right go ahead okay so he
isn't still sad so anyway I met the
right people that's what you everyone
has to remember ed ingles sports
director for WCS him watching me handle
myself how I handle myself
especially dealing with some lay you're
always watching right and when you don't
think they are and that's very great
thank you for saying that's a very good
point and you know getting back can I
fast forward a little bit nope that's
one of the messages I always say because
I'm very something I'm really no means
no now what are they I'm not only small
we Ellis everybody's watching I know I
need your story because we're not going
to get tell me the whole podcast go just
go to Calgary Olympics can I mean can we
go so watching earth first by the way
all this led to me being the first woman
sports doing sports reports in New York
on the radio WCBS ed Ingalls hired me to
do sports updates overnight that will
repeat it over and over and over again
this is before WFAN all sports talk
radio then WFAN hired stop mm-hmm how
many years up so you you're put your
playing field hockey in college right no
no ice hockey's that feels are getting
last long too boring with in high school
respect you're playing hockey you get
this first job News Ryan wants sports so
you go and hustle it right they want
somebody said sees you lighting and
hires you to do the overnight thing
right how quickly did that all happen
that happened within after one hockey
season right so about a year after year
like because one hockey season then he's
higher meted then he says hey you want
to cover the Mets at Shea doing this
hey you want to cover the u.s. open for
us yes yes yes yes hey you want to do
sports updates oh yes within a year and
how at this point are you feeling any
flack for this is what 1980 well yeah
well here's the thing yet this is all in
the mid 80s and also I was on sports
phone which is a legendary thing we used
to do sports updates in a room that was
the size of a telephone booth and people
would pay people would pay gamblers
would pay big time because that's what
it was
I love you Kyler's a degenerate and will
probably be dead in a year I mean he
just careful haven't you cable so many
things there's a lot of animals would be
rock about how long this interview with
every wake up is really sick they're in
denial I don't expect him to be around
much longer
no I mean I just hired Z today new
assistants veering away too much death
talk in this episode he Muslim valet all
right keep the were on so we do it so
seven days a week seven days a week
seven days a week long at FA n I said
and I was doing local cable TV could do
sports wasn't allowed what did I do
I baked cookies for the camera crew one
afternoon
so I can tape put together a sports tape
I created my own sports tape for a local
Long Island TV so I could send it out to
cities where I wanted to live Gary and
one of those cities was Seattle
Washington
why do you want to live in Seattle
because in Calgary when I went out there
I fell in line to Calgary because I was
also at a million of jobs that I worked
seven days a week was ABC radio where I
did sports update and back in then in
1988 ABC had the rights to the Olympics
so Calgary was the Winter Olympics in
1988 I went out there fun Fadel Ryan
leach and Brian Rick brought Brian
Leetch and a micro a courier on that ad
a US team and later became Rangers and
won the actual Cup but the Rangers
flyways and that team in Calgary was an
embarrassment Russians destroyed the
shaf they didn't Rogers even war I am
finished eighth eighth didn't even make
me male competition little did I know
they would be winning the cup for my
dream team so yeah so that's the whole
Calgary thing and it also Rangers they
traded when he was young to the
Blackhawks Amato
Oh Tony Amato and he was looking at was
a big trade because that brought back my
cart
yeah I think my car is a big I think it
was my garden maybe now he needs a lot
on that 88 Olympic team might have been
because his name just popped in my head
and I don't know cuz i only remember
Richard mergers I knew that all right
all right so let's let's pass for you so
you know you go to college Academy real
quickly I apologize for I don't I have
it Noland I have to because I'm on a
show yes but I want to bring value to
the audience because you took every soon
that I get a hundred [ __ ] emails a
day of people say I want to be a rap
star I want to be a country star I want
to be a YouTube star and they don't work
anywhere close to seven days a week
you're about to tell a story of how you
got into the [ __ ] Hall of Fame
whether legit or not all on a back exit
okay all in the back of working seven
days a week if you weren't in all the
hustle you're doing you're [ __ ]
driving too [ __ ] long I lose it on
top of everything you do to save me
seizing which takes you to Calgary yep
which makes you what happens in Calgary
but I fell in love with Calgary and I go
wait a minute I want to move to Canada
remember I love hockey but that was in
LA gistic at that point in my life and
realest
stick so what is the equivalent so I
asked one of our producers who's working
with me I said what's an American city
that most like calculation goes why not
come visit me in Seattle in July again I
was there February come visit me in July
you can drop off your tape that's what
you did back then to news directors the
CBS the ABC the NBC affiliate in Seattle
colleges real quick and I'll go ahead
you [ __ ] faces want to become famous and
win and Linda how to wait from February
to [ __ ] July to drop off a tape but
you can DM [ __ ] on Instagram right
now while you're listening Linda do you
understand I'm pissed people are crying
that they can't make it and they can
literally [ __ ] DM people yet you have
to wait from [ __ ] February to July to
drop off a [ __ ] tape you get a
hundred emails I get a hundred e but yet
I have people that I respond to
first of all I love giving back when if
you ask me I'm Ellen fast-forwarding I
know you want my whole timeline but I
got to get this in because it's really
important to me
all that [ __ ] never would have happened
if I wasn't grateful and if I wasn't
just living and doing what I really
wanted not worried about what happens if
like worrying about [ __ ] that may never
ever happen just move forward just keep
going so anyway it's important to me
right now to get back because when I see
qualities of myself just like you when
you go back and you do your little
little people have little podcast a
little radio through that's what I try
to do and that's what I accomplish
because I see you do it and that means a
lot to me and it means so much but then
there is people out there that I think
have such balls like they'll get my
email address but I'll applaud them
because then they're like hey Leland
this is where it gets bad though there's
this one woman got my email address all
right true story
great I'm ready to applaud I'm ready to
reply back to her hey Wow great looking
to help what's your story then she says
hey is it ok if I send you my resume so
you can hand it to somebody that turned
me off Gary because she thought you
weren't big enough like important like
no if she thought she'd want she stopped
doing the work I think she she just lies
around upon that because with giving
with expectation right I understand why
didn't you pick my brain you have my
attention
you're all mine hall-of-famer right and
it's legit
you know what I'm saying yes I never I
did it's important so when I when I do
which I love doing and I've been doing
it speaking engagements you know keno
doing things like that I love the
opportunity just like you to touch
people I know I'm completely obsessed
with you and listen but it's like
neutral but I know it sounds like a love
fest here I'm sorry but it's truth and
the other thing is it's really true when
I'm like traveling yourself I do I'm
like I'm looking at YouTube and looking
you to see what kind of stuff I can
steal from you if that's okay full
disclosure a lot of stealing from hi
baby want everything stolen okay I'm
putting it out all right free Linda
Calgary you fall in love you go to
Seattle what's happening
Seattle great six months into the
Seattle gig ESPN calls me that time I
was married my husband at the time said
to me I didn't drop my job not that it
was a high paying job in his book he
goes I didn't drop my job who 3,000
miles only to move all the way back
within six months we're staying and
guess what of all the things that was a
positive that was good advice because I
was able with some of this hone my
skills I had a chance to uncover the
Mariners the Seahawks you know all the
packed you know at that time obviously
washing the Huskies of Sonics were
they're really hold my skills and also I
stopped I had a kid I had my daughter
Sammy you're going to meet I had my
daughter Sammy there and I kind of like
that slowed down not slowed down how
does the rishi old were you able that
that's why I had 30 oh really why so
this matched out okay we did and that's
into that are watching listening in all
that Gary there's always hope it doesn't
matter what age here well your was
that's what this was 19 I went out to
Seattle in October of 89 and by 1990 GRE
I want you right but by 90 they want to
be but I had to turn on my album ago and
then I had to say listen how if they
want me it was tough it was a Valentine
ESPN was into it clearly an honest way
yeah totally on it's my whole life was
about sprite or like 1990 can you have
it I mean that pre-internet
it's everything well you guys weren't
even born yet these [ __ ] does but you
know and then we're baby
fifteen focused fine so it works exactly
the special 15 and crying over the judge
1992 a lot dr dad good you know and so
so anyway yet so so I just figured and
after some basics in therapy and slowing
down my life a little and having the you
know balance but still having that urge
to accomplish and keep going next level
and be better I had a child it was great
and then they called again - and who
years late so my contract in Seattle was
three years they called two and a half
years in so Seattle let me move the
contract early the bosses are you know
al Jesse who was the talent guy at ESPN
and he called again flew me out to
Bristol again and then we talked and
said they wanted to hire me and they
wanted to hire me to host SportsCenter
and also be reported turned out it was
more SportsCenter they wanted me and Ben
to this day the people there in and
around I'm still highlights are the
thing that I do well why because I've
always because I played the games you
know what I'm saying and I get and I get
it from an athlete's point of view I
wasn't in there
to make people cry and win Emmys do you
understand Gary and there's so many
people in our business that the toll
they care about and that was never it
for me because I just loved having this
to me it was it was a the high it was a
legal high was that roller coaster that
I so loved being a fan and I'll never
forget being a fan and I'm always a fan
first to this day and getting back to
your earlier point you always make the
least someone who's watching you for the
very first time people always say how do
you keep this going how do you stay
fresh how does it instill mean something
to use is when you're doing something as
big as that you are getting people
seeing you for the first time yes
including athletes and that was the
great opportunity because then a sleet's
can see that I'm not a fraud that I
really did love sports well the hockey
guys must obsess over you it's such a
small culture of actually no hockey they
push they know that it's true I mean
they definitely it's dead or none
there's like is it the best when you go
join arms it's weighted or not even
anywhere where do you feel I figured oh
look yeah what if you want my off leg
can I work here well anytime I'm I'm
good right now we'll work it out I'm
telling you I mean just see Ron you're
fired
I know so
so Linda now I'm going to be RIT before
we get into the question yeah because I
can't stop talking to you 19 months so
when do you go to SportsCenter 19 1992
July 19 - just celebrated 25 years July
1st right so like amazing
congratulations that is like the golden
era for a lot of people yes of
personalities Keith and damn yeah and
like Stuart I get like like that's when
all of you guys making up all sorts of
words just to top each other that is
like the golden era of SportsCenter but
it was one of the cultural phenomena and
so true so you walk in and what happened
first day you walk in give me even
before fers-rae even before if done that
day take it away I still in Seattle
moving I called my friend who was
working there Gary Miller okay Gary
great broadcaster back in the day my
fact great Gary Miller story and it's
timely oj Bronco ride Gary and I were
scheduled to do the 11:00 p.m. Eastern
SportsCenter on that amazing night where
we all thought he was going to blow his
brains out in 1994 of course Knicks and
Roger saying I was literally waiting out
there right I got all three but yeah
okay so that's what Gary but that's
fast-forward that was 1994 Gary Miller
get away okay so get all right so mr.
Sportello why before I even go there so
I go get I talked to Gary he says Linda
I just gotta warn you you know not
mourning but you know he was buddies
with Dan Patrick I said can I talk to
Dan about me coming there you know and
Dan as you mentioned staple with Keith
Olbermann the big show big guy I'll
never forget what Dan said to me you
know he said you realize and he may have
said a tongue-in-cheek because you know
Dan Patrick is a funny guy yes and he
said to me as you realize every woman
before you has basically failed here I
mean talk about rolling out the red
carpet
yeah and so imagine that you know here
you are not that story is that's a hell
of a lot better than keep did yeah
looking at you know and I love koe
something specially if you like you know
it's a piece of work yep well I how did
that go with you like that was great but
I you go through a phase and I think a
lot of you know the ppb slowly and Dan
[ __ ] you I played hockey with
seven-year-old boy see I wish I could
see that's where the little girl comes
out and that's part of my message when I
speak to people and I speak guys
gals because a lot of self-esteem issues
and I still fight it to the stay carry
fighting that little girl and giving
that little girl inside me a hug so what
did I never met them huh but the chip is
good it's an engine yeah you want to
give it a hug will give you know you
don't know you wanna hurt us or eeeh
yeah well that truly keeps us going 100%
if I didn't handle that made me drink
piss out of a Pepsi toss or in Dover New
Jersey when I was four I'm basically
going to build an empire just stick it
down their [ __ ] throat I'll tell you
some something ironic one of my
colleagues still works at ESPN me
leverage okay right Neil great guy right
when I was going through one of those
moments where I wasn't feeling confident
myself we all get it yes he said to me
do you know who you are
I go Who am I he goes yeah he goes he
goes Catwoman actually she goes um your
LFC and I go LSC you're Linda [ __ ]
comb and then one day I was visiting my
brother dr. Howard Cohen in Orange
County where the doctors in the bill
that his company seven-point-two is in a
building we were outside we were
chatting I looked up at the top of his
building what did it say LFC love that I
love that zone crazy man
so what happened so give me give me one
store first of all the oj story you guys
were supposed to be alampi and real and
obviously is going on earlier in the day
yes Co special happening the game was
late was right right they ESPN was
having the ABC news feed so you didn't
get any sports on ESPN 2 o'clock they
took over the page they took over the
feed and we just all everybody everybody
together let's watch OJ and he's going
to blow his head off
yeah you know and with everything we all
saw it and I'll never forget what me and
Carrie here's the monitors in the desk
yes I wear glasses
the whole damn time and we had a staple
and it and when did he pull into the
wonder that I want to say was like 1:30
a.m. Eastern Time some Loretta you know
don't quote me sure that it was in the
we al you guys don't have a Sports
Center now we didn't have a sports in it
they kept that news going so you know I
mean it was some phone calls
yes places how sure your just light of a
nice for you it's your hockey season you
excited
understood Tyler thanks for ruining Java
Debbie damn reason powder brought that
up little behind the scenes the reason
we've been debating that I cut off
guests is when I know that I have other
meetings behind it I'm trying to fit it
in and when I when I have nothing behind
it I don't so that was actually a great
job by Tyler because right he can feel
me I'd already started feeling a little
pressure good job well done
well John this is Gary B you're on the
askgaryvee show with the legend linda
cone hi John that is that is also hey
guys how are you great what's your
question so myself along with a group of
investors recently bought the
International racquetball tour and we
are trying to create or find ways to
create a national media exposure and
that better to get advice from them you
guys that is a very good point yeah
first of all is racquetball still a
sport
yes I mean you know there are so many
different definitions of racquetball of
what it used to be
same with handball I know there are
different ways you know what you just
did it was you just basically turned
into Dan Patrick you literally just did
to this lovely man from saying I know
exactly what Dan Patrick did to you I
know all right
continued continued John racquetball is
going to be the biggest sport in America
in 37 yeah you make a deal with snapchat
as an OTT play and you develop stars the
way sunny world and created Joe Namath
the key for sports is distribution and
star making so the advice I give you is
you need to look at Facebook Netflix
Amazon and those players as you're OTT
not ESPN not ABC and then that
conglomerate Disney or CBS or NBC
because I'm going to be looking at it
differently I'm going to make you pay to
even be on there because that's what
they do with small things and I think
then you've got to find the most
handsome or beautiful racquetball player
with charisma in the world and make them
a social media star and now you've got a
prayer to have something begin but
here's the thing we love goofy things
and we put it on top 10 we put on the
cornhole yes championship yes ok
and unlike as I'm reading the
the top ten I'm like what the hell did I
just read what does well mean what is
good
that's right of thing exactly what you
said getting a pretty person or
something sure goofy and crazy to get
exposure Scott its star making and
distribution in a modern way the same
way that ESPN had to start off with
bullfighting and and Zoran John or Scott
is it John I keep going scarlet there's
a German audience to play in John shell
John can you chain on into number three
work okay John I think you guys probably
know that to move right yeah I think so
you know we've got we've got to take
this opportunity that we have you know
we've got some very marketable stars out
there right and believe it or not we
have over a hundred events a year with
pride versus of 60,000 dollars and more
and I mean event but trying to get out
of that box has proven difficult from
the past owners and now that we have a
group of investors that are willing to
spend the money and and figure this out
we're very motivating man
it might just where it used to be my man
you are the poker tournaments pre ESPN
coverage the problem is ESPN is not the
place you should do that now with you
need to figure out basically the same
model for the new environment of
consumption I like that I appreciate so
I really think about what OTT means
Netflix and Hulu and Amazon and Facebook
and snapchat and Twitter are the preview
there are going to be so many places
content has never been in a better place
you need to cold email Bleacher Report
and barstool an ESPN Android like you
have to find distribution because I if
you gave me the New York Jets right now
if you said hey I'm John Scott like
genie from the future and if you can
name one racquetball player one I will
give you the New York Jets
I would lose I cannot name one
racquetball player nor can i and when
the cone is a whole favor legit legit so
that's the amount distribution good luck
my man
thank you very much forever guys it's
all distribution it's all about
distribution it's about getting
awareness and then it's having the right
product for the new
medium I would argue in a 360 camera
world racquetball might be in the best
place it's ever been because of you
think about the dynamics of that sport
much like American football needed
television to break through the radio
right much like radio was a great boxing
and horse racing in baseball's right and
NFL football and basketball did great on
television what sports will do great in
a mobile 360 VRA our world set a GoPro
thing on one of these guys heads I mean
that's like oh my gosh who do we have
next
suanne like I cannot believe you were
doing Sports Center the night of Oh
giant yes incorrect I get back to that
minute other memorable nights you know
tell me if you've been on with like
President Joe Carter Joe Carter when he
at home run works at night know
presidents don't don't good no no were
you all I like in the build I was in
that building design jewelry no I do K
hangers out of the hall I have a grace
are all stuff I have a right to sue and
devastating next okay listen
Game seven Rangers Devil's conference
final perhaps the most amazing game
double overtime a Toma Toma toe that
night I was doing the six o'clock
SportsCenter got up to do in a with
Charlie Steiner I said and that's when
ESPN Charlie he is fine I'm unboxing
well if it's you've been doing Dodgers
play-by-play forever on the radio doing
the 6:00 p.m. Sports Center that night
we had hockey back then I said Rangers
Devils were next it's going to be a
classic I had no idea it really was but
then my bosses said Linda we need to
talk to you before you go home I go wait
there's a game I gotta go home 11 I got
to go home I didn't I clearer the game
blah blah blah cuz I had to work you
know and so he's like I won't take long
that's when they basically said they
almost fired me I had to this is a true
story I almost got fired on the night of
Game seven Rangers Devils because they
weren't happy with my work they love me
as a human they knew I love sports
they said it's not coming out enough
this is two years into my contract Wow
I had a two-year contract with an option
for two more they said we're going to
keep the option but only for one year
but we're going to need to see something
improvement within six months so I was
basically a lame-duck
so here
I am at ESPN dream job two years in no
feedback oh by the way for the first two
years telling me good or bad
suddenly night of Game seven you know
that's when they say hey we know you
know sports you talk about all the time
was difficult analogy because everybody
was so hyperbolized on SportsCenter at
that point I mean that was a low humming
goodbye I just making up [ __ ] every
night right they just felt that I didn't
feel comfortable is almost like when the
red light went on it wasn't the
confirmation I'm pretty pissed yeah what
I could say I think I feel like that was
during a stick era you and I was not
cheating right you were depth right a
zephyr getting back to Keith and Dan
which was a big that that thank you and
that's where I felt it was it was I was
like what are you back voice of reason
and what I loved about not having a
so-called cliche and I tried to catch
phrases you know for lower elevation and
all that you know under guide oh and my
classic story about master batter yeah
that was course you know a great name
for saltiness the master batters you
know so you know with someone it's a
home run right you know okay good I know
you guys just so quick well yeah I'm
kind of today well we're doing good
we're hitting okay how about the night
week look like now in Jackson I'm going
no I'm going all over the place now you
in Seattle the night Mike Tyson lost to
Buster Douglas right because I was
1990-91 yes not 790 yes now yes so it
was February 90 it so I don't really
know this I did not go to school that
Monday because I was in a state of shock
as long as you weren't crying I cried
yeah soprano guys force was my whole
life I would cry if I was up at I went
out on a limb on now remember do you
remember the night Tyson last night it
was a very horrible shocking thing in
boxing history that is a monkey I would
argue that better standing in Leon
Spinks a hundred first of all I wasn't
around for that yeah I was not also
around for the 80 match so like I was
too young yeah I but I mean in boxing no
question do you think it's I think it's
the most shocking moment in sports
history for somebody that's 41 years old
help me here what would happen the last
30 years that is more shock
then Buster Douglas beating Mike Tyson
the Patriots coming back from a 28 3
deficit to beat the Falcons and the
Superbowl is not true you want a fun
fact I do not watch one play a vegetable
yeah nor any other Super Bowl the
Patriots of venom the last three out of
four times must have been better watch
yeah wasn't shocking I would argue that
the Jets Monday night miracle named
Monday night miracle was more shocking
there was eight people left in that
[ __ ] Stadium we're losing thirty to
seven with ten minutes left and we won
and what did you win exactly the
greatest moment of my life actually this
is a true story the greatest moment of
my life is when the Jets beat the
Patriots in the second round of Navajos
now when a stunning is that one Bart
Scott I can't wait yes al Dantonio best
day in my life I've been married I have
two children that say my life that day
my life
jets beating Patriots in the second
round of playoffs not a Super Bowl not
even ing chanting to name a divisional
playoff game nobody thought they were
going to win I thought I was going up to
Boston to lose 55 to 6 was my official
prediction they'd lost 45 to 3 even
reached six weeks earlier best day ever
ever I understand that I understand you
should love Tom Brady he's all about
nutrition he's got a book coming out
tv12 you're about fitness you know I
mean this guy I what you know he's your
guy you just don't know it yet said I
will say this and I'm never in minutes
anybody other than you okay breaks my
heart but this is a good human being see
Michael Jordan's easy he's a terrible
right so he was easy to consume because
yes he destroyed my heart and made me
cry often but thank god he's an awful
guy hmm
Tom on the other hand great human seems
to be the case yeah where were we were
you calling
maybe a weird right by the way nice to
Hong Kong a lot only Hong Kong is going
woo Julie its Gary B you're a barrel
Julie this is Gary B hey Gary Vee how
are you I'm good how are you
you all know how are you great hello
you from Jules I'm good where you from
Jules I'm in Charlotte North Carolina
alone oh that's awesome what can we help
you with all right I've got two
questions for y'all makeup for Sue and
my first one is about NASCAR if you look
in the stands during a NASCAR race yeah
these days they're basically empty yep
what does NASCAR need to do to rebrand
and market in this era yeah it is really
on the downturn now that Dale jr. the
most popular driver probably in all of
NASCAR history when you think about it
in this world is retiring age is going
to join NBC these guys I mean they're
just not the personality are not there
you know you tell me who's your favorite
driver is it a guy like Kyle Busch is
that you know I mean who is a guy that
lights your fire because you need more
drivers that light fires
well obviously Jimmie Johnson he's the
all-american you had Jeff Gordon
everybody food he retired around you
what's up you know it's funny I'm
sitting here so are you a big NASCAR fan
I'm really not but I live in Charlotte
North Carolina so it's really the home
of a lot of drivers not far from a lot
of their shops so this is going to be
great I'm glad I asked that because it's
going to be easier for me to say what
I'm going to say I'm really very excited
about NASCAR's downturn because I bet
the farm with a bunch of my friends
seven eight years ago when NASCAR was
clearly on the way up yeah that it
wasn't sustainable and that I thought
the bottom was going to fall out and so
I'm proud of myself why did she sound
curious Gary why did you think that I
thought that they were doing so I'm a
big believer in tripling down on your
strengths and staying through your DNA I
had felt that there was so much momentum
going on that they started creating
behavior in the NASCAR ecosystem that
seemed to me more Super Bowl esque more
mainstream sports what they were trying
to earth expand and and I think they
took their fans for granted I think they
felt that their tried and true would
stay there and I thought they made a
terrible bet on not I thought they were
one of the worst organizations with the
digital world that was coming behind
they were super behind they shouldn't
ripple downing on letting their drivers
do thing and I felt like they became
more money oriented and more mainstream
than more long-term tried and true and
completely they should have really
really really embraced social and
digital they went the other way and I
think it cost them and I just it's I
mean it's crazy
the waiting's on TV are non-existent
yeah Julie's educating me to me it's
already a foregone conclusion I didn't
realize the stands were that empty and I
didn't even know when I heard that
jay'll jr. is going to join NBC and I'm
like I didn't even know they had NASCAR
I don't know where to look to finance
car yeah I mean so do I know you got a
second question let's get to that here's
my punchline
I think what they need to do is
modernize and story-tell where people
are and by the way Joey this is my
recommendation for all organization
Linda's beloved hockey is stunningly
irrelevant as well yes regional true its
regional like NASCAR that's right and
what baseball is becoming 100% my ass
got a story tell in a modern way this is
where the NBA has gone global and
completely embraced and I'm unbelievably
bullish on the NBA while quite concerned
about things like NASCAR hockey and and
and baseball's interesting because I
think it has a a lock on entertainment
during the summer to go to is there's no
complication and so I think they're in
my spies so saying is I think the USFL
should come back
I think spring football should come back
I have been having real dreams later of
rebooting the USFL starting a spring
football league because I think it would
work because I think football is so
popular in America that think about all
the great college players that don't
make the league
it will not be the NFL but spring
football would work in this country I
totally agree people are killing for
what CFL highlights and loving and
loving the I do Arena box all of my life
Julie second question second question
what are your thoughts on the lack of
coverage for the Tour de France and do
you think since the Lance era in quotes
there that cycling in America has faded
I barely knew was here yeah Linda I'm
telling you no fair I couldn't care less
nobody cares I got respect overseas in
Europe they love it they love the
cycling people ride their bikes in this
country but they're not doing it here we
live in America yeah like I think we
like them Aaron oil yeah you know what
[ __ ] bikes I know there is no Gary Barry
they're in our way
Jerry they're in our lane listen Julie
this is clap you know what America
somebody wasn't born in America the
thing I respect is such a happy American
the thing I respect about America is
also its weakness we're so insular like
we're finally getting around to soccer
but like if you're doing well outside
the US as a sport we have spikes
say [ __ ] you like Formula one go [ __ ]
yourself like cycling go [ __ ] yourself
and for a long time even soccer
we're just funny that way don't shove it
down my throat though with the soccer I
mean I have a hard time I got to do I
like you work for the organization as
well shut up there I know that they say
Sokka is being as the smartest when they
sign the right
all of a sudden miraculously after they
lock up the World Cup for the rest of
our lives they start showing me top 10
plays from [ __ ] Europe right and it's
always number one size is always number
one in points and chick from lucky guy
I'm in so long
all right let's move on to what Julie
you're the best well thank you for
calling thanks guys
by the way Julie that wasn't great at
holy yeah that was a great great call
had culture and sports mix in will give
you one more Andy in the face of Tyler's
face depends which Linda do you think
that we should start a daily sports
radio show can you fit it in your
schedule and light everyone you know no
I know that we're not talking about life
I'm talking about in sports radio right
now is number one I can fulfill
no no I mean I'm suddenly minutes late
for dinner that's fine all right Linda
cone the legend right Ollie Mae are
similar televised
tell Constantine we'll be fine tell them
who's this Nick from Bowling Green
nicolau yes man you really traded you've
won this rare I mean the odds of you
pretty
through were very high but you did a
Nick from Bowling Green nerd that is
amazing I can't I just showed up with
like this might be vaynermedia but we're
not sure okay we're familiar going on up
what Alan knows you in it's awesome Wow
so what's your question brother ah
actually um yeah my my my guess man
golly cool hold on ahead I like relaxed
a little bit Oh deep breaths device Mike
my question is is so I feel like like I
was listening to you I've done a lot of
your concerned a lot of your content I'm
trying to dwindle that and just hustle
and work my seniors is like you said be
self-aware and I realize I know I'm not
an entrepreneur I guarantee it like I'm
just not organized enough not anal
enough yeah Oh real quick I am neither
organized or anal be you man be you so
you know yeah what I am okay I'll get
really fearless and that is that to me
is the one that you need to because
entrepreneurship is lonely and scary
yeah and that's the thing is like I
don't like I can't do that like I mean
I've had discussions with my father he
thinks that he can good for you and I'm
just like we can't so I wish I know it's
hard I mean it like yeah good for you so
what so what's the punchline so the
point is is like I think I have a talent
for talking and just just talking about
like football cuz I'm in love with
football which I think it's I mean like
who's your team in I'm on I the
Tennessee Titans definitely for most are
not battling now if there is an amazing
signing and I think Mariota a
breakthrough player stay healthy yeah
yeah absolutely yeah that's the thing is
Lauren's you stays healthy man I'm
excited about this year like I thought
USA Today was like hey they're gonna be
12 and for like qualifying USA TODAY's
are they still in any flavor by the way
that speaking with me today since I've
seen USA Today so the Jets were gonna be
one in 15 and I was like yes Sam Donald
if you love Josh yeah I don't exactly
exactly I know what I really want to go
on you know he wants to win with your
team I'm sure he did you ever and and
Marshall had to say Matt yeah they had
to apologize up the high road Nick
I don't know if you heard Melinda and I
are starting what's going to be the
number one anywhere's radio show in
America we probably need a third member
you could be like that sidekick honestly
honestly the thing is is like that's
exactly what I want to do I want what is
doing about it other than the random
lottery that might have just happened
that has no chance of hi make for
Bowling Green yes and Gary and me so
what I'm doing if I do any time without
content every day you should basically
create SportsCenter on Twitter and the
Instagram everyday phone to your beauty
to anything it's so easy now
yeah Linda's pitch him to gussy my
February [ __ ] July she said it a
[ __ ] tape buddy walked across the
country let your Bible is gonna tape for
six months when I'm doing I go okay what
I'm doing is I'm getting I'm getting in
contact especially with fantasy football
of podcast producer and I'm offering
opportunities for me to just read
articles that happen to be on their site
good that they can't read and sending it
to but I wouldn't reading or they don't
have time to read it it's more than a
problem they probably just don't have
time to read because I mean if they're
doing podcast Lord willing they have
good voices in there shouldn't reading
are you called you couldn't meaning yes
I'm very good at reading my favorite
reading
no really I'm [ __ ] I loved reading I was
always the kid that's in a class and I
never liked I probably would have been a
problem would be in the sports
broadcasting Hall of Fame if I could
read I probably would I probably would
have went down that wire our radio show
it's going to work because you don't
have to read you're just talking it's
awesome you're weaving in and out ideas
and opinions Linda Nick from Bowling
Green I have something amazing to tell
you I did a show on Sirius called wyman
web for last seven months with Jake's
dad well we're and there's a connection
benroubi
a legend radio executive the first
outside be nothing I prepped nothing I
do my first show I go in and it goes to
commercial times and I have to do a live
read in the history of my life I've
never done anything more embarrassing
how long did it take you to get through
the 32nd Oh seven years seven not one
time I like a complete disaster I
[ __ ] like I'm you know I never get
flustered but like I won't even like
read the [ __ ] like Jewish stuff at
Rosh Hashanah because I'm like so bad if
I don't yes that so I am flustered
salmon and Ruby runs in everything up to
this point is like legend like I'm going
to be the next [ __ ] at Howard Stern but
now he walks in goes [ __ ] he goes okay
listen do what Howard did read it before
hand and then improv it literally the
next commercial the greatest live read
of call in the history of radio
that's why Howard's great because he did
that and you don't get sloppy did I
agree is this is real the producer of
that show yeah Jordan emailed me
randomly the other day he has the tape
so I'm going to air it so you two have a
tape I I have okay listen I'm 40 I'm no
spring [ __ ] chicken I call it taste
new Nick from Bowling Green what else
are you doing
because randomly DMing people that have
sports fantasy sports podcasts and
offering to read things for them feels
okay I feel like there's more moves than
you I
I tried starting a vlog and tried to
know if you're not tried I recorded one
video of me I guess like my fear about
the document versus creating is like if
I'm going to do something about sport
like I would be better if I've got like
um somebody to partner with and I'm not
saying like y'all I'm not saying that at
all cuddle but like being able to have
somebody who is like a an analyst but
then be able to have me where I could
just talk to them like yeah yeah exactly
yeah yang you feel yes exactly exactly
okay well good news oh what's your
what's your Twitter handle ah @n per kid
my last name at and per guess spelling
change it
a lot fancier Lancome yes that's my last
name yeah somebody needs a banner Chuck
do not change it just spell it for me
n okay PRI thank you you EG te linda
that's like a classic book in hockey you
ask me why are you mad at him I'm not
sure we'll try to figure it out later
but we understand he's better playing
off people because so low it's a little
slow listen yes listen
Linda's give me you honestly wall of
Famers know how to analyze legit right
how would you say I'm doing okay PLAs
thank you and Nick from Bowling Green
when a solo Nick Nate's like I like this
not give me they'll give me the answer
Howie tailed what's the grade at the
grade right now I'm not going to ask
Iman I would III think he could do Marco
C - okay Nick Amin a plus your C my
being kind Nick yes we know she really
want to give a nap I think the fact you
just put out your handle we're going to
throw it up on everything here there are
thousands of people who follow me that
love sports who think they're the yin to
your yang and they're going to connect
with you on Twitter and you're literally
going to find your partner in crime
through getting through to this call and
it's going to change your life and
there's gonna be a 34:31 day in 71 years
Nick from Bowling Green and Sally from
Arkansas and Nick block out the noise
ignore the the ugly mentions you might
get on Twitter after this okay you never
Bay that's fine okay I will because you
have to you know that's gary gnosis you
have to treat the good news with the bad
news the good reaction to the rear
daniels window I know you do right look
well when you showed me that Penguins
paddle Chris secretly I was like [ __ ]
you know what if this is what I love for
money video I you everything you're
saying I know I love her on your videos
it's like don't just rip me rip my
opinion
tell me what's better I love it give me
your opinion but that's what I love that
you say that in your videos so the
people have grabbed with his stupid
mentions a hundred listen I prefer the
negativity because it feeds me I prefer
the positivity because it feeds me
now what yeah I'm all about fine the
positive right I thought Nick was a
little too negative and I don't think
still sure about Nick [ __ ] the rest
minute they're in bad girl ey oh yes
please : go ahead what I gave him a
c-minus as I felt bad I ripped his neck
don't you think yeah I would just I was
just saying like like Linda like I know
I got it so I got a c-minus because
you're being sweet and nice and I rip
your name and I felt bad
no that's okay no no it's okay I'm going
to get I'm gonna get [ __ ] for my name
anyway it's alright um the thing is I
want your your critique I once your neck
well not your negative but like you're
critiquing of why I made the C - as
opposed to I mean obviously I can't go
against whatever I'm going to jump in
I'm going to jump in here's what I want
to say if this Cole has continued yes
ad nauseam on how long it's been I agree
has been we haven't even started or in
the national anthem of a 19mm game to
give you context of how long I'm
flipping on Nick Nick sombrio late in
the game Islanders [ __ ] capitals
playoff yeah its five-year time fellas
run bags what this cold turn into okay
Tyler's wedding
Constantine's that some [ __ ] sushi
prize runner when you're a Sammy maybe
at the graduation I mean hey you know
doctors in the building like this is
this [ __ ] Latino that's the only County
and I know that like a like a pharma
companies good friend of mine Ali's
clients but he like back in there and
Nick when we reveal you've loosened up
as his Cole's gone along which shows
progress which I found deposited is now
a real see might now I know it's not I
really think once he has some material
talked about and feel comfortable in its
surroundings and knows that he belongs
in a situation I think his personality
will come out and he'll challenge those
he works with hey Nick look at oh you
curveball that's intended with serious
love ready okay I'm going to give you an
F and I'm going to tell you why it's not
that I actually mean it but I'm going to
try to inspire you love you and
everybody else the number of people that
I asked for critiques and phone calls I
made to critique me and what I did in my
career
goose [ __ ] egg as a matter of fact
Robert Parish double goose egg Wow
I would tell you that I am obsessed with
doing let me give you a really really
really good piece of advice for you and
everybody else Linda out the gate right
playing hockey with the boys she just
did she would hear feedback but she did
did did I genuinely believe that people
looking for feedback or perfection
there's just a million excuses for not
doing you should 100% produce audio
podcast form audio files on an anchor
you're following me [ __ ] play along
and do sports center play along with
somebody like just do brother
everybody's coming up with excuses it
comes from insecurity I get it but the
reason I want to give you an F is I want
you to hang up and be like you know what
[ __ ] Linda [ __ ] Gary I'm going to go out
and just do [ __ ] like just start putting
stuff on I'm going to use a joke here
put [ __ ] on tape just [ __ ] lid I had
to [ __ ] bake [ __ ] cookies to trick
people into producing something that
could be seen you can sit in your
[ __ ] underpants in an hour and of ten
thousand times more people see it in an
hour
Nick you're living through the greatest
era of production and distribution of
content in the history of mankind take
advantage of it block out all the other
voices [ __ ] everybody else and I can do
got it got it good you never want to
look back and say it and try that's not
yeah just do man door who gives a [ __ ]
with Linda's I don't give a [ __ ] that
she's all the same actually I am Prateek
I do in college I muscle it all the
Famer all-time appearances on
SportsCenter trying to years in those
[ __ ] I said to her you're on the way
out on what does that have to tell you
yeah
don't you understand good see ya okay
Nick Linda yeah I love you same here me
I've got to go now Constantine give my
regards you get to ask the question of
the day any question you want thousands
of answers on Facebook and YouTube
question of the day this is that that
like serious meaning this or can be like
the money question you want okay a
sports question would be preferable guy
like Cyrus with you and I think Jets so
to me this current scene we know you
don't want them to win again
let's also cooler because you're such a
[ __ ] genius encyclopedia take me back
to an era where you asked in tell me
what the Jets are going to do this year
how ask me something like Steve Young
Randle cunning say something about
black' or like what what about McDonald
the Calvary [ __ ] mustache give me
something about like like something
really voters I know you're like these
are chavanel I Meldrick Taylor would it
give me something real afraid nerd all
right well here's the thing being a
goalie and you mentioned about how I
created this tape and I made cookies you
do this and I made this happen on that
tape remember this was like early 80s
okay this was like yeah is in mid 80s
because it was got me the job at Seattle
in 88
so I was around 87 86 there was a goalie
who had a serious injury and it was so
disgusting to look at and it was
something out of Game of Thrones you
could make the case do you remember that
goal lose name star it was not a North
Star
I don't okay but you wanted me to try to
you know that's it that's it and the
winner the first person to answer
correctly in the comments gets bitter
with Linda cone the legend that's right
I hope it's another goalie you're
awesome all right Thank You Larry
you keep asking questions we'll keep
answering them
[Music]
Oh